I started to hear just how novel these
particular inoculants were and hearing
how novel they were coupled with the
claim that they were exceedingly safe
raised alarm bells for me because I knew
that a vaccine that was truly
functioning by a novel mechanism
that had only been around for a a short
number of months could not possibly be
known to be safe even if it would
ultimately be proved harmless there's no
way anybody could tell you that it was
ultimately going to be harmless and so
that alarm caused Heather and me to
decide to delay although we thought we
would be vaccinated we decided let's
wait we were not initially eligible and
we said actually we're in no rush let's
wait let's give it you know a couple
months to see if an adverse event signal
shows up that tells us anything that we
would want to know before making that
decision and of course the longer we
waited the stranger the story became yes
the adverse event signal did begin to
show up and no nobody seemed to be
paying attention to it they seem to be
deliberately avoiding the information
and so I think
I would be remiss if I did not point out
that one of the strangest features of
the story that you have just told is
your reaction which is highly unusual
amongst doctors I don't think it should
be but I have now watched doctor after
doctor fail to make eye contact with
this pattern and it does raise a
question that I have been very eager to
pose to you which is
at this point we have a an absolutely
alarming and unprecedented signal not
only in the vares system here in the U.S
but in the yellow card system in Europe
and in the American Military system
which is completely isolated from any of
the the things that people accuse the
Vare system of
the pattern is clear
how is it possible
that doctors are not rising up on mass
and telling us wait a minute something
has emerged in the context of these
vaccines that ought to have us at the
very least going exceedingly slow if not
as you propose simply ending the program
until we know what's taking place yeah
it's a great question bro I think just
to add in you're absolutely right we've
got this Pharmaca vigilance data in the
US UK unprecedented unprecedented
reports of Harms
um for example in the UK um for the
Pfizer vaccine there were 500 000 half a
million
um Adverse Events reported on the yellow
card scheme
um which uh is is unheard of and uh that
you know people don't fill in these
these yellow cards or the vars unless
there's something significant it isn't
usually even people have a sore arm or a
fever they don't report on these on
these so there's clearly something there
but what I would say before answering
your question directly
for me the icing on the cake if you like
or The Smoking Gun is the uh re-analysis
of Pfizer moderna's original randomized
control trials by
um you know very eminent scientists
Joseph Freeman who I've spoken to lead
Author Peter Doshi from University of
Maryland associated with the bmj Robert
Kaplan from Stanford is uh published in
vaccine peer review journal is they were
found in the original trials the this
the rate of serious Adverse Events was
about 1 in 800. for every 800 people
vaccinated in the trial there was one
serious adverse event and and what's
most extraordinary rare is they were you
were more likely to suffer a serious
adverse event in the original RCT
then one was to suffer um
hospitalization from covid so what that
tells so we've actually got the highest
possible quality level of data there's
you know there's not even observational
this is randomized control trial
evidence for me that should be more than
enough
um to suspend the vaccine because that
is a very you know very significant and
very strong quality data
so the question is why is there this
turning a blind eye so I think the best
way to describe it
um is willful blindness
so this is a a condition something that
happens in with human beings it can
happen in
um in individual relationships we're all
capable of it it can be you know in in a
way that people maybe turn a blind eye
or to the fact that their spouse may be
cheating on them it can happen in
institutions we see what happened with
for example in Hollywood and Harvey
Weinstein
um it can happen in populations and
countries you know what happened in Nazi
Germany for example why how did the
German population not know for so long
that Jewish people were being massacred
in concentration camps or maybe they did
know but they turned a blind eye so we
call this wolf or blindness and to
Define it more specifically it's when
humans turn a blind eye to the truth in
order to feel safe
to avoid conflict
um to reduce anxiety and to protect
Prestige and I think that's what we are
seeing now in relation to many people's
reaction to this issue about covered
vaccine harms I think one other thing to
throw into the equation as well which I
was thinking about recently
um Brett is that
um fear
is inversely correlated with people's
ability to engage in critical thinking
and many of the people I think certainly
if you look at the reaction certainly
anecdotally and there's definitely been
there was a greater fear and
understandably so amongst older
populations around covid and I think
those people are also the same people
who are probably more likely to be
really adherent to masking
Etc and I think that that is still
playing a role because many people still
have this very grossly exaggerated fear
of covid and therefore in order to feel
safe when they were offered and said
listen we've got this solution it's
going to end the pandemic here's a
vaccine they embraced it wholeheartedly
and I still and I think it's very
difficult for them to suddenly it's not
easy for those people to suddenly change
their minds and of course you know
um Jordan Peterson talks about this so
changing one's mind is one of the most
terrifying experiences a human being can
face in Academia we know that you know
there's a there's a great quote from
John Kenneth Galbraith the Canadian
American Economist who said you know
faced with a choice between changing
one's mind and proving there's no reason
to do so
almost everybody gets busy on the proof
so I think we have to try and understand
that The Human Condition to explain some
of this Behavior but
um the way to tackle it is actually just
by by addressing those issues or those
um uh those um that denialism with cold
hard facts but to do in a compassionate
way so I think when people understand
that we're all capable for blame as I
could say to some degree I will I was
willfully blind when I was being told
that the vaccine could be causing
problems certainly for a while
then I think that's the way to approach
trying to get more and more people on
board
well I I hear what you're saying and I'm
all for approaching this compassionately
to a point but nonetheless you are
describing a failure that words seen in
the general public okay but we're
talking about doctors and what I have
witnessed is
doctors who are in no way Fringe highly
decorated fully qualified doctors in the
exact area you would hope they would be
in order to make such a pronouncement
attempting to raise the alarm of their
colleagues and being
demonized and stigmatized and
marginalized in many cases
systematically
now
I guess I think one cannot have it both
ways
that happens it has caused doctors to
recoil in fear to make themselves and I
100 agree with your diagnosis it is a
blindness that is on uh the user's side
they are willfully blinding themselves
to a pattern that you couldn't miss if
you were just simply committed to an
objective analysis
but for doctors to be vulnerable to that
within their own areas of specialty in
many cases says something about
the state of medical education it says
something about the incentives that
surround doctoring
and
uh I know that it has left me in a
predicament where
I'm literally afraid to go to the doctor
even if I was if I broke my leg
um I know what conversation I'm going to
have when I arrive at the ER and the
conversation is going to involve my
vaccination status and at the point that
I say I am not vaccinated for covid
most doctors will look at me as if I
have just confessed to an
anti-scientific highly political bent
when all I've really done is just simply
looked at my own health looked at the
actual evidence of utility of the
vaccines looked at the evidence of the
potential harms and decided that no cost
benefit analysis could possibly justify
my accepting these things
so uh I guess
you know you're obviously a very
uh decent person and I hear I hear you
looking out for you know the
vulnerabilities the psychological
vulnerabilities that make this happen to
people and uh trying to be careful about
how we approach it but haven't you just
um if we look at your your argument from
the other side haven't we just
effectively indicted your profession
yeah Brett we have
um and I you know I have uh I
communicate in different ways and I'm
considered quite forthright and a bit of
a Maverick and uh and very assertive in
My Views throughout my career whether
it's around cholesterol or sugar or
statins or corruption in the drug
industry
um
I'm with you completely and I think it's
it's very this is we're not just
fighting for
transparency of data in relation to the
vaccine and
fighting for
um those people who've been vaccine
injured uh and fighting for what I would
say is really a pause in the vaccine and
investigation we're also fighting for
really um the medical profession now and
in terms of restoring trust because the
trust is clearly gone to a significant
degree we know that the certainly in the
UK we are seeing the fact that even for
the traditional vaccines we've talked
about which you know in comparison to
most other drugs are extremely safe and
have proven very effective that there's
been a um a reduction in people
attending or having uptake for things
like MMR musics and rubella vaccines and
that is a uh is symptomatic of the fact
that there is clearly a reduction in
trust and that reduction in trust has
happened because of these coercive
policies that have been pushed by many
of establishment doctors
and I think that that is
um something that will take a long time
um to to restore that trust but we have
to do what we can as a best and to the
best of our ability
right now to make sure that that shift
and that acknowledgment happened sooner
rather than later but
um I I'm completely with you I I get it
and I think that some of it also
unfortunately Brett is based upon the
fact that he's you know you've hinted at
these structural drivers these perverse
incentives in the Healthcare System
anyway
um we know for example we've even
pre-covered it's something I talk about
as a very you know vocal Advocate and
campaigner for a sustainable National
Health Service
um which you know was founded on the
principles of giving
um Everybody the best care free at the
point of use
is that the American Healthcare System
in an example where you have some of the
highest expenditure on Healthcare in the
world and certainly within the developed
countries some of the worst Health
outcomes and that's pre-covered and one
of the reasons for that is because of
the commercial Corruption of medicine if
you like perverse incentives
over diagnosis ordering tests that
people don't need in order to make money
so that trust already I think in the
United States amongst doctors certainly
was lower than in the UK because of this
and I think the covert pandemic has only
probably made that worse breath
unfortunately
no it uh it clearly has taken anybody
who uh had trepidations and uh Amplified
them to a spectacular degree I really
I I frankly do not know how we rescue
medicine from what it has just done
especially you know what what I'm
watching in the U.S is not only are we
failing to make eye contact
with the harms literally gaslighting
people who have been been vaccine
injured and pretending that we don't
know what's taking place with them
but we are also continuing to do the
harm
right by failing to risk stratify the
population and you know I I agree with
you that these the vaccine campaign
should be halted on the basis of the
Adverse Events
and the uh relatively low danger of the
disease in question also the low
efficacy of uh the the inoculants but
the the idea that we are vaccinating
young people in some cases we are
requiring them to get vaccinated in
order to go to college and that we are
contemplating requiring children of all
people to get these things to just
simply get an education this is not a
matter of us simply not recognizing what
we've done we're still doing it and so
you know how does any credibility how is
it left over after that yeah I mean am I
wrong that every cardiologist must know
that this is taking place that their the
willful blindness has to be extreme for
them to avoid it yeah so it's
interesting on the cardiologist stuff um
after my papers are published uh
recently then you know it was shared
amongst many people it's got a lot of a
lot of views a lot of attention even if
it hasn't broken the mainstream in the
UK in the way we wanted it to but the
feedback from cardiologists has been
pretty extraordinary in terms of them
thinking ah like a light bulb moment
thank you Asim brilliant this makes
sense
um I've had feedback from certainly one
cardiologist in a in a well-known
teaching Hospital in London and said
that after reading the paper almost
everybody all the cardiologists are
meeting said we're not having any
boosters
so you know it resonates with them
because again as I said the evidence is
clear
[Music]
thank you